[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to be talking about the
business of cannabis we have John
Morocco joining us on the show hello how
you doing thank you
thanks for coming on my man really
appreciate absolutely and this is great
because it's super local to our boys
right upstairs yep fifth floor yep
yeah and his company is highways
highways is - about two years old now
and they're doing the cutting edge San
Francisco work in distributing cannabis
yeah very important stuff and this is
very important on the medicinal side
this is very important on the
recreational side I'm getting all of
these getting the getting the this
beautiful product of Earth into the
hands of the people finally absolutely
getting through this BS war on drug
stuff yeah getting right through it oh I
love it so John and I will be jumping at
the depth of that you can check out
highways through the links in the bio
and their Instagram links in the bio go
and check them out
we like starting with the big history
kind of state of humanity so you know we
find ourselves as stewards of Earth John
and what's your current take on what's
going on with humanity
well humanity to me starts from from the
original seed you know the way you're
raised up and how your environment
influences you and how your parents
raised you if you have parents
determines the whole state of your
living which ultimately is humanity you
know in today's society we're not really
passed down with culture usually we're
from different areas people are first
second generation and now in today's
thing we got to be raised up off the
culture of America and it's more so you
learn this in school not at home so
that's that's a big problem from the
get-go you know and then as we're
raising up humanity it comes to a point
where everyone's for this concept of the
dollar figure and not for the people and
then people's thoughts are revolve
around that and it changes a lot of
functions between humanity and society
you know what I'm saying so I think
Humanity is a
level problem from the pure environment
from young and also cultural barriers
between people you know that's that's
how I see it and then going forward
there's a lot of advancing things with
technology you know that can be used to
benefit people but if only if we use it
in the right way for the environment for
our people you know I'm saying without
the dollar in mind
I like how you went to the seed because
yes that's it when that mind is first
birthed into the world it's the
responsibility of the parents and the
community or that it's around the
environment that it's around the child's
around in order to mold that mind in the
most aware way possible into the world
and a lot of some of the traumas and the
issues that we see in our world stem
from that seed being improperly watered
or nurture and etc that's good that you
that you start us there like that all
right so well I'm sure this that point
is gonna come back into our conversation
get it seed seed of cannabis seed of the
child's mind it'll come back in the
conversation remove many more times now
this is a complicated thing getting
involved in the cannabis business yeah
because there's a lot of things to deal
with there is the laws there that are
slowly becoming more and more flexible
and liberal there's the the taxes
there's all of the kind of like the
companies that are getting in the the
grow sites the testing that goes into
the product the distribution of the
product and this is a very complex beast
to deal with and so tell us about how
you even got it started in your mind
that you wanted to get involved and
you're watching the industry yeah back
to the seed you know I was growing up a
lot of people around me smoked cannabis
it was a big thing even though I grew up
in New York in a small area you know
saying and it wasn't legal everyone was
still smoking I'm saying even
schoolteachers even doctors in our area
we knew you don't say even former police
cops people always were talking about it
so it was always a thing growing up and
then my family moved out here so I
followed them I went to USF and as I
came here I followed the movement
between the market rates and I studied
cannabis law in my free time all I was
going to school so it was a very
interesting thing was a hobby and it was
something I talked about amongst peers
you know
and from learning through that you know
I got kind of involved I was living in
San Francisco at the time so it only
made sense and I applied for a license
and I my mom my mother applied for a
license cuz I wasn't old enough and with
my help and you know her activity we got
the license and that was that was the
start of it it's interesting growing up
in a place like New York where you're
seeing the doctors and other adults that
are professionals in their fields that
are using cannabis yes
versus for me in South Dakota it was no
no no no none of that right and then
there's a more liberal places like the
Netherlands right in the world so it's
kind of like these varying degrees of
like liberal mispers conservative with
cannabis use and even prior to you know
the last hundred years of what we've
seen with drugs prior to that it was you
know just a natural plant of earth that
we were that we were using so okay so
while you're watching you know the
growing industry and you're figuring out
your you're studying cannabis law
figuring out how to get involved what
were some of those like key points that
you took away that you were like okay I
see how to get in etc
oh really just reading up on all the new
laws and regulations because even now
the laws still in our and they're still
being changed all the time so it's
really just reading up and following it
day to day I did have my father and
peers around me who were also kind of
involved looking at the laws and stuff
and I had some friends in the industry
even though I moved here I still consume
cannabis I went to dispensaries so
meeting people going the shows I was
involved in then what you find a key
point where some was like hey this is
going on hey that's going on you know I
decided to what jump in
interesting now kind of like coming to
the seed of you know you getting
involved again now how did you end up
like kind of positioning yourself to get
started then cuz you said you and your
mom when it applied we are originally we
started as a collective like everyone
else people collectively would get
products for people grow products for
people and do it as a nonprofit do it to
service other people you know some
people originally that we had some are
younger people but a lot we're also sick
people can't leave their houses so it
originally started as this medical thing
where people who are paralyzed and have
serious defects people grow for those
people people have collective
memberships where they provide services
to those people and then they would
hopefully get reimburse it back for
their time and stuff as a collective
start in the first year you know you
lose money but it's also in the good
feet of things so we started off as a
collective we went on read maps back in
the day you know and then built from the
ground up there and as a collective once
it transferred over
we found our position to apply for a
license with the transfer and then we
were granted one okay very interesting
so does everyone have to start at the
collective level no no okay so you can
apply straight to the license level yes
now you can but before you couldn't
before you could get grandfathered in
and before you could still apply for one
interesting now starting at the
collective level is it is easier in a
sense because you kind of get your
footing and you have a higher likelihood
of getting a license yeah you don't have
to spend so much money for the Green
Zone property and nowadays are so many
laws and regulations it's different so
when you start out as a collective you
could start really with with no footing
and just start you know a collective
means collectively amongst people even
if you were to give meds to two people
you know what I'm saying it's still a
collective so it was definitely a very
easier way to get involved as it wasn't
for profit interesting and that's just
filing with the state yeah
so Colorado Washington Cali etc you're
just you're going through the state
capital saying I want to be a collective
it's different in every state different
Everest
and then different in every County it
really trickles down yeah
whoa okay so different for every county
even okay and then once you get the
acceptance of a collective then whether
you're helping two people or helping
five or ten etc more people that usually
what you're doing is collective is
you're a non-profit yeah okay and then
you're taking cannabis from the local
like County that is B it's being grown
in or maybe a county nearby and you're
taking the cannabis and then you're dis
your distributor as the collective
uh-huh so yes or yeah that's pretty much
the broad sense of it okay interesting
and it can be anything from flower to
tinctures edibles etc topicals yeah yeah
like you know like I said back in the
collective days some of these products
weren't around that as is now but yeah
okay okay and then now this
transitionary period how does one do the
whole collective to license again that
is that different for every county in
every state now in days you can't do
that because those days are kind of over
and now it's just straight up applying
for a license which a lot of people have
already gotten in the process of in some
counties are are coming down to where
there's no more licensing and then you
do equity um you know pretty much and
then big businesses are starting to come
in so you know you'd have to get
property find the right place have
someone who cooperates in the business
and then apply excetera through that
hopefully one of the counties are still
taking licensing or you do some type of
equity fit to try and apply for one so
what's a the number of licenses per
county varies yeah but is it usually
around like 10 it's up to the county so
they can say yes to one they could say
yes to five they could say yes to 30
summer beds you know and they're just
like it's not allowed
woah can a county ban even though the
state says yes um it's in the works
right now the laws are still not
concluded there's still discussion about
this about this state county thing um it
shouldn't be banned in a whole sense you
know people like I said if you can't
leave your house and you need cannabis
and it actually helps you you should be
allowed to have it delivered into your
band count
I think that's only right right you know
cuz they're gonna get it regardless you
know they're not gonna stop so yeah a
lot of the organized crime networks and
violence that we see is actually a big
the reason why it exists because of the
war on drugs yeah so we could have got
rid of prohibition handled this in a
more ethical and more humanitarian and a
more a plants of the earth reason it
started off as a hippie movement you
know people were originally hippies
believing this cool calm thing there was
usually nice gatherings you know people
some people who smoke I've even sold
before and gotten paranoid people can
get paranoid to have their first
experiences and get this bad persona or
might not want to do it again vice versa
other people who've never tried it this
smells bad the appeals bad but it
started off as a hippie thing my father
was a hippie you know back in the days
and it transfer does this kind of like
community sensual thing peace and love
and happiness and then it got illegal it
got very profitable and then it became
sort of this illegal thing where you
need someone who's intelligent but also
is a criminal in a sense to sell massive
amounts of cannabis so now being a
dominant industry player it turns into
this illegal market and all the
prejudice about it just makes it even
worse for people you know like I said
even back home where was illegal I knew
working people who smoked it but you
know everyone didn't know you know I'm
saying maybe someone's parent or someone
you knew from the from the area but it
wasn't a pronounced thing it was kind of
kept in the darks and when things are
kept in the dark and when things
involved cash handlings it does become
criminal you know and it definitely
couldn't have been that way it could
have been a more beneficial way but you
know yeah yeah there's a couple things
of where I want to go one of the things
that you mentioned I think is super
important is this whole idea of like
first experiences with with medicine
some of the earth and I think one of the
one of the main issues here is that with
this lack of research and development we
don't actually know oh your entire like
let's say biometrics day and it was knew
that about you and
knew exactly what we were making as a
cannabinoid profile and that we knew
exactly the milligram dosage that you
would desire whether it just be three or
whether it be ten or twenty whatever
that it's just very interesting that if
we had the proper research and
development tools we could make it so
that we can decrease the amount of poor
experiences young people are having yeah
that's that's a great way of looking at
and that definitely can be done in a
sense yeah yeah okay so let now let's go
to the the where we were at which this
is very interesting you were teaching me
about this and I think this is extremely
important to mention so you have these
these licenses that are being given and
these licenses depending on the county
is you know 120 none etc then there's
more nuance that goes into it such as
these green zones mhm this is this was
very interesting you can't be near a
school and then there's other what are
the other like nuances here yeah there's
other in detail things the main concept
would be a school and it's it's
pronounced just an appropriate place to
conduct business of cannabis you know
necessarily more so like an industrial
area where you're away from people you
know and then you can make you could do
your wholesale operations you know kind
of the same concept as like a Jack
Daniel's plan you're not gonna put one
in the center of a neighborhood you know
what I'm saying
so that type of concept of the Green
Zone is how they look at it okay and
then now when you're deciding on you
know location you were also pointing out
how there's some you know ma and pas
peeps that are coming in there's some
corporate peeps that are coming in and
then they're you know you're identifying
a location you're setting up shop and
then you know we have some of your
products here and there's your picking
kind of who you want to work with in
terms of distribution of their product
lines yeah and then you're and then
you're also picking by the location that
you find yourself in your community that
you serve anyways yeah no you know like
I said it started off as a collective so
some of these brands have you
to start his collectives build their
brand gain a following and go forward or
vice versa so some people partner with
corporations or big businesses come on
board and obtain a license with somebody
without somebody and it really started
as people in the community who smoked
developed brands and develop all these
strains all the strains you see now all
the things that are good that are people
are smoking have been in the works for 5
10 15 years you know and then that goes
back into the concept of like the equity
and the this and that and how is it fair
and the people who are making laws
trying to be fair even though they don't
have this extreme knowledge and feedback
is that a people who develop this
industry should get grandfathered in and
there is grandfathering laws there are
equity to help people who have been
affected by the war but you know it's
still hard for some people some people
who are farming who you know just let's
just say a name gelato grew gelato and
now it's this big thing and then you go
legal and now they don't have the same
clientele or you know cycle they have to
build it a different way you know what
I'm saying and pay high taxes and pay
the water and board to get their
structures up to code it can be
difficult and a lot of people find it
hard to get a license and some people
who have actually built this industry
aren't around you know and people who
want to be there's not a lot of leeway
between the laws and now you have to
follow it exactly as it is you know like
even for us we do decent revenue we are
expanding we collect a lot of attacks
for the city and state but it is high
and it definitely hurts the business a
lot on a ground point you know also why
would you go to a dispensary you know
saying if you could just go down the
street especially in San Francisco you
know we all can see the the inner
streets of San Francisco and what needs
to go on and that people are not just
selling cannabis cannabis is not even
bothered but people are selling cannabis
on the street weight cheaper than a
store you know saying and then that's
really when it comes down to just the
brands hold the uniqueness in it but to
gain that market we need to lower the
taxes and absorb this black market that
you know can't isn't just gonna go away
damn you went to so many places there
whoa oh yeah yeah cool so you it was all
the way to the collective's that were
first forming when they were figuring
out how to you know do you spend
sometimes up 15 more years of building
up their their brand and their product
and the ones that are some of them that
started making the industry what it is
are gone now
due to some of the of the regulations
that have potentially been placed on
them some of the yeah I've heard we've
heard stories of a batches of cannabis
that have that went through testing that
you know that that that have failed that
when you test them again they don't fail
so there's all this because then there
you have to test for like mold and
pesticides and all this other kind of
stuff to make sure that that and
consumer is using a good product and
then you took us through also through
the taxes and kind of how crazy that is
if there was a more transparent way that
everyone could see the dollars from the
cannabis industry and how they're going
to maybe affordable housing maybe how
they're going to solving some of the
yeah the problems that we have yeah um
really I think I think you know that
there was a budget place on this and
there was an appropriated number that
was supposed to be allocated towards
paying for all of these resources and I
don't think the state hit the threshold
that they were supposed to and so that I
don't think that it generated enough
profit to actually go towards that and I
think that they're working on
readjusting some of the ideas that they
initially had you know I think a big
thing would be taking on people who are
in the cannabis industry and then
hearing what they have to say you know
what I'm saying and it's just kind of at
this point right now where the state's
trying to make it work and they need to
readjust some of those some of the laws
that are going into this you know
especially like excise tax is very high
from business down to consumer you
noticing and it's the same concept that
they need to raise more revenue on the
legal side you know what I'm saying to
gain that profitability where we can put
it into schools and education and lights
on the streets you know
yeah that's right yes yes and this is so
so important because this this amount of
tax money going to transportation
education all these crazy important
fields human flourishing just to be able
to do that more effectively with the
legalization of drugs and the research
and development of drugs is so so
important now I think it's important to
identify kind of what's going on with
some of the you know we started we
started tackling this you know you're
you're taking these products you're
you're helping be a dispensary and then
there's a bunch of other dispensaries
that are doing the same thing you're
kind of trying to build your brand
differentiate yourself some deliver some
don't some go on platforms like ease
mm-hm and weed maps some don't mm-hmm so
what is kind of like what like why why
people make decisions like that well I
could say from from how we perceive you
know we started off with this
connoisseur thing you know we're we're a
brand and a whole sense I've been
involved in things not just retail
retail would be like the last thing I've
helped cultivate which is Central
Florida that you could see you know
there's from cultivation to making
products to just developing all these
things and I think everybody has to hit
their everyone hits their niche really
you know a lot of brands that you see
now that have been around they hit their
niche some cultivate you know some are
good at making oils some are gonna just
flat-out growing outdoors you don't see
not making strains so everyone kind of
hits their niche and sees sees where
their part is you know an our thing is
highways you know highways represents
all the highways that we went in and out
meeting with brands getting products and
that's where I don't even comes from on
the retail sense you know and then we
also have only exclusives which is more
of the community a lot of people know us
a lot of other companies know us we've
been at a lot of shows and events you
know what we show face very well we know
our knowledge about the products we have
a lot of collective people who were
cultivating really good strains that
were highly know
I'm been sold to very well-known
dispensaries you know so it really
depends where you fit what you're trying
to be in our trademark staple is we're
trying to be that retail that is based
out of San Francisco there's a lot of
other people that aren't based here
delivering to here yeah you know and
they can't source such a big menu we
source a great menu from products that
we all try and we like to smoke as all
those you know we try almost all of our
products and that's where the retail
goes but on the bigger sense for us
we're trying to make that vertical
integration when we can be known for our
cultivation strains you know and be
known for our nice delivery and and do
that vertical integration where we can
go from A to Z because everyone in our
network is that a twosie thing and I
look to bring the people amongst my
group together to what to be known you
know maybe something like a jungle boys
you know which a lot of people who smoke
know about how they cultivate their own
stuff and they sell it as well yeah this
is good that you're starting to take us
here
Ronnie John said he had that image for
cultivation yep
yeah so let's um let's pull that one up
cuz I want I think this is this is gonna
be interesting to start talking about it
from this in this perspective so alright
so certain people tackle different neat
niches in the cannabis business yeah
so some slowly cultivate some so Lee
distributes some cultivate edible or
topical tincture etc and there's
vertical integration which you started
in Jeannette there's horizontal
integration which is very interesting as
well if you just try and get tons and
tons of these pull up plots of land and
just grow it at like Israeli prices like
14 bucks an ounce
you know and then there's you know this
vertical integration that you were
hinting at as well as that if you are
here and then you're taking it from here
and bringing it through the testing
phase bringing it through your store
bringing it through the distribution all
the way to the customer that's your
vertical
so you are identifying that you guys
want to be vertically integrated that so
teach us more about kind of like you
know why why does someone like you guys
pick to be vertically integrated um it's
I don't think wants the right word yes
we want to you know but we have like I
said I have a cultivator who cultivates
great streams I mean you know I'm saying
the dude just grows for himself in his
house and self-tests of stuff I've I've
self tested it but I've had another
company tested for its clean you know he
smokes it and it's great stuff it's
better than a lot of the stuff out here
it's better than almost everything out
here you don't saying that a lot of
people know about I think that I want to
bring my partner my friend my associate
to light bring him to legal cultivation
and that would necessarily be kind of
that vertical thing so we're bringing
him on board yeah we do have a
distribution license that we're looking
to work on we're building it out right
now that could be brought to
distribution to retail and then um I
just like to control the products we
have that go in and out and I think it's
it's a big fit for us to to have that
you know especially when you know like I
said if you look at a really known
strain like even cookies the brand they
have great strains but you know they
have the license and we need to get that
license you know bring it to light and
then we'll be out retail with these
strains so it's you know it's a choice
and it's also bringing our brand to
light pretty much yeah and it's also
this community that you're hinting at
too is that you found someone that's
doing a really good job and you bring
them to light through what you've built
as well and they help you guys out by
providing you with a really good product
that you guys work with closely you know
you're also talking about this as a
medicine as well earlier and I think
this is if not you know what one of the
most important aspects of this as humans
that need is first sleep-eating pain
there's so many ways to you and there's
so many different methods to use canvas
so many different dosages to use so many
different cannabinoids to use so you
where do you see this now as a meta
coming into industry I think that after
it goes federally legal we'll see a lot
of R&D as people are doing it now but
it'll be done on a way higher
advancement once it goes legal and we'll
see a lot of big changes like I see you
know I've seen the CBD actually help
people my father's friend was had lung
cancer in the hospital they they
pronounced him three to seven days to
live you know he lived two months after
that and lived instead of being on
morphine and couldn't breathe he was
talking and walking so I seen that you
know saying not firsthand but heard the
stories I've you know I I know the guy
had lung cancer and I've seen even on
the news you see people who have
seizures that take these things and are
cured or not cured not cured but are so
it severely helps their symptoms you
know and it's a really big thing and I
think going back to the humanity tickets
like if you see where this is benefiting
somebody you know why not make it legal
in a sense you know saying and you see
some of these people move out of state
to go where it's legal to do it and then
I think also on another aspect that it
does help a lot of people like it helps
people to sleep helps people with hunger
helps people to de-stress you know I
know a lot of people I've collectively
delivered to a lot of people who are
like man you know without this I'd be
angry you don't know saying about this I
can't eat without this I can't sleep you
know and they resort to other things you
know yeah
man all those stories are so important
to share because then that's what can
get us closer to the federal level of
legalization and all the research and
development that can go into this the
more can get into the hands of people
that need it as a medicine as well eat
it as a plant of earth as the healing
properties that it that it brings now
you know you you were also talking about
this from a perspective of you know what
what will happen to the black market as
the federal legalization comes in this
is very interesting as well the decrease
in organized crime the decrease in
violence the potentially the the more
easy it is for people to get it as a
medicine for a bid for cannabis
businesses to flourish teach us about
what you think of that times
yeah the decriminalization for cannabis
is that market is coming to an end you
know as far as that stopping people
doing criminal things it's not gonna
stop some people do what they do and it
actually becomes worse now because
they're not making money off of cannabis
so you can see like really crazy people
even San Francisco go different routes
do different jobs per se you know and
the D criminal yeah the
decriminalization it's a lot of people
are gonna shine to let I think I think
people want to be people who do it
illegally or semi legally or fully
illegally that make these products and
do the cultivation would like to go to
light if they can you know and some
other people that are just doing it
purely for profit and do it as a
criminal enterprise you know it's gonna
be diminished you know but I think first
of all the state and the government has
to come up with a plan and I think the
initial plan is kind of the tax thing
you'd understand where you it's a
competitive market if you have lower
prices people go to storefronts you know
saying mmhmm yeah that's interesting
that's a very lower lower prices on the
on the lake well we see I think it's
like something ridiculous forty cents a
gram in Israel or something like that
that if the price is actually that low I
mean people are gonna go to the legal
the legalized route yeah getting the
products okay then no one on the streets
will sell if it's 40 cents a gram that's
no one will waste their time on that but
then like you indicated people will
transition to other things so then it's
important to potentially legalize and
and manage the distribution of other
drugs as well and research and
development there ok let's talk on the
actual products and strains this is this
is cool because you have you've brought
us some of what you guys have yes I have
so yeah so teach us about what you have
here why you've selected to go with with
brands like this and and what exactly
these are yeah you know we've uh you
know like I said we've I run through so
many different companies we try out so
many different things and we want to
have a menu of products that are what we
like to smoke you don't know saying like
we've got the LA Kush over here this
stuff you know this is some great stuff
right here you know it comes all the way
from LA from our from our friend company
they bring it back up here it's
exceptional cannabis as far as justice
reigns the way it hits it's something
that we like to smoke and having on the
menu everyone else feels the same way
and from that to even nameless which is
down in our Southern California they're
a really well-known company and I think
that it comes down to the flavor and how
smooth the smoke is on these strains you
know the great companies man we
definitely want to keep them on the menu
we definitely shout them out and stuff
be something that consumers love you
know no matter what and then we have
other companies that we're trying to
bring to light like head stashes as a
newer company they're also based out of
San Francisco I personally think their
products very good I'm so do my partners
and my my managers so they get to smoke
these these are products we got to try
it out and then put it on the menu for
people to share their experiences and
feel the same way that's these are all
indoors except for the bon vivant which
would be cultivated in a greenhouse
lights up situation and even though it's
a little bit lesser quality because it's
not indoor it's an amazing smoke and I
would say that them not being in indoor
really isn't that big of a difference
and also on a more legal aspect just the
way they brand these items like all
these are these are legal brands and the
packaging is amaze
yeah and just something you want to
consume without even opening you want to
try it yeah that's right from even the
outside yeah yeah they do a great job at
that and then you know the nut these
nugs are just like they're gorgeous yeah
they're gorgeous
and like you said a lot of this is the
taste the way it smokes yep and then
that's why you keep it in your product
line yes okay and that's now you know
some of these are sourced actually a
decent amount of them are sourced from
Southern California like Los Angeles um
like nameless in LA cush is there's a
lot of brands down there yeah yeah not
you guys there's a lot downer that we do
like it's cool and we are very in touch
with the LA market and with the LA
brands down there that's cool that's
cool but then you can't can you source
of Denver and Washington that said no no
you can't cross state lines um not right
now in the future you definitely you
definitely will be able to and people
might have really big facilities where
they they can push it out through state
wide you know um interesting you can't
distribute through through there's you
can do whatever you want it well that's
why there's the market the black market
betting exactly man yeah you with the
regulation you can get this over there
but you know you're on this way yeah
that's interesting that rich the
restrictions in place people will still
get what they want
yeah yeah and then that's also you see
some of these brands will partner up and
actually franchise into other states so
people can actually access them which is
very expensive very intricate you know
in a sense
so these are these all flower these are
all flowers are all flower what what
percentage of your inventory is flower
versus other products yeah I mean I want
to say like 80% you know a lot a lot of
its flower I think flower you know it
you could see the older market and all
this and that people moving away towards
cartridges and vaping yeah you know but
we'd like to have that flower keep it
old-school keep some of these strains
that you know people really you know
want to get you know I think vaping
vaping is a cool thing you know but
everything comes down to the terpenes
and the flavor of your of your product
you know and a lot of the stuff that's
this lit you know it's distally did you
know substances you know it's not the
actual things so that's why you're like
like this you gotten into concentrates
which have the full embodiment of the
whole plant that you can taste and feel
you know so I think interesting I think
you know I don't know the right word is
but the way it is it's the best way to
consume it you know understanding and
not being changed in its in its original
form yeah because this is it's
interesting 80% of your inventories
flower and I'll and you speak about it
from a very kind of like ogee way is
that you get the full effects of all the
plant
verse is actually taking it and and
distilling it and then you have to do
things like actually like extract out
all the what you used to distill it yes
yeah there's like this becomes a
complicated process and you add not only
complexity but potential you're changing
obviously a lot from a flower to it to a
distillate that you can then put into a
vape pen or a topical or an edible etc
some people can't smoke they need to do
an edible or a topical etc so there's
you know there's a reason why now does
that mean eighty percent a round of your
sales are also in their flower um you
know eighty percent just a roundabout
number yeah the exact I'm sure is
probably seventy percent you know twenty
percent ten percent with edibles being
the lowest edibles at lower
concentrating in the middle okay you
know people definitely try a lot of
different things
I think the brands out there now are
very
brands you know there's good stuff
people to smoke in California I think
that you know we try to relate with the
people you know some prices are high
we're trying to to be that that average
price thing where everybody can afford
it you know and really have that whole
full-bodied sense you know from flower
to concentrates but to really just have
the the flavor as the embodiment yeah
you know they're that flavorful and
buttery now is this is this is really
interesting because when I'm reading
this I'm seeing you know they have this
down you know 19.6% total THC THC a
twenty two point one nine percent total
CBD one point one nine percent like this
is very very precise you know this has
to be properly tested absolutely
documented and labeled and etc this is
where we're going with this kind of
precision cannabis which is very
exciting
yeah it is great you know if you smoking
real compliance stuff man it's smooth
its clean and it feels great you know
and then that's another thing about our
business I think that we're so
passionate well we know a lot of these
companies that we really understand
what's going on from the testing what
CBD is CBG and all these other things
and putting our two cents into making
some products that that can change the
market maybe change the way people are
getting their products from A to B and
how they're consuming them
no name just flame this is branding so
great mega wellness nameless genetics
interesting I mean next time we'll smoke
lanaaaa
yeah smoke [ __ ] smoke on set on set
next time yeah quite a bit waitin for ya
Ron's me the way you're waiting for it
little wake and bake
yeah okay now okay couple things on the
way out that I that I think are
important to target here you guys to
teach us about what it's like to
actually set up the infrastructure to be
able to take a consumer request from
your local area and then be able to take
your inventory and distribute it to them
yeah it's pretty much you know you got a
call you get an order online it
transfers her receptionist i'll they
take it down they get the products they
shoot it out and then it's either you
know GPS tracked and then the call
outside they come downstairs they get
their products you know in a simple
general sense um we have a lot of
different ways where we're looking to
take the business we're looking to take
an approach words may be quicker
deliveries and though maybe we can come
up to your door and just thinking about
different ways of presenting the product
and getting the product to the people
you know without receptionist you know
through online using all these new IT
things you know and and really see where
it takes us so then there's a decent
amount of IT infrastructure that goes
into this because then you have to
manage your inventory you have to have a
place for people to enter their
potentially their credit card
information and process it via online
marketplace that kind of stuff and then
you have to track it do the GPS tracking
in one on yes so so it's it's like it's
like it's like any other business it's
just more regulated and there's some
companies that you need that aren't that
are fully there yet so you know it's
cool man it's it's really for me from
the ground up to now it's definitely
really a corporation you know you gotta
follow all the rules you gotta establish
your things correctly you got to really
know the laws and how you're moving
forward you know and it's gettin it's
gettin good it's trying to light I think
the state started and the
stay as the general is starting to
realize some of the problems with with
the people with the consumers with the
retail and the taxes they're trying to
do a changement I think that the
industry is going in a good direction so
far for the compliancy and I think that
the in my team could put in some really
good products and put some really good
new exciting ways to what to change this
business and how you get your products
you know from exit backs the
presentation to to new to new you know
devices and new ways of consuming
cannabis you know that my guys are
working on that's exciting yeah I'm
excited to see what you guys have coming
out
yeah devices presentations all this kind
of stuff is exciting to see what what's
coming out there seem to be quite a bit
of quite a big movement towards these
really tiny tiny yes yet people just
like to you know that's kind of their
like go-to thing but then all this new
ways of like packaging flour be very
beautifully and present a very
beautifully with the scientific you know
labeling as well of all the testing okay
what else about industry do you think
it's important to highlight about the
business of cannabis where it's where
it's at where it's going I think
cannabis you know cannabis is one of
those last those last originating things
cannabis is something that you know it's
the last end of the Prohibition this
might be one of the last movements for
it
you know and it's interesting because
it's prohibition it's connecting a dark
world with a light world you know a plus
B good+ bed young to old I think it
brings people together I think it's
making a lot of people open their eyes I
think if enhanced in the right way we
could be going towards a good movement
for the community for the the world as a
general because it brings people
together it's a new point of discussion
and it's really an eye opener you know
from the ground up to to a guy selling a
bag on a corner all the way up to where
they're they're thinking about rding in
different countries you know I think
there's a lot of good things to be done
a lot of great products to come out and
I think it can help people seriously on
all sorts of levels even young kids to
adults from stress to society and as a
whole and I think we need to have people
who know what they're talking about and
with the corporations as well and that
fact that humanity that if we can work
together and come up with some nice
solutions with some nice IT that in 20
30 years we'll be seeing some some great
advancements and some really good
healing properties of for everyone in a
whole it's a good vision for it is a
really strong vision it's it's a lot to
take in it is it's a lot it's a lot to
take in because you see things from from
a bunch of the different angles
obviously and so when you know when
you're speaking uh when you're speaking
about it with that vision it's really
powerful because then it it it really
resonates with with others and for like
for me super excited to see it enter
into our sphere in a more holistic way
yeah absolutely you know I've seen it
from all angles you noticing I am young
I am the CEO operating the business so I
know the law is hard I know how to
process finances to talk between other
businessman to organize your your unit
you know your family your corporation
you know what I'm saying and I've I've
seen it on the back end you know even
when I was back growing up in New York
getting dime bags used to call it for
$10 right you know and it was it was
this business that was within a business
but you know wasn't a legal business so
you see a lot of really crazy things
going on between people trying to do
this do that how they sell it how you
legally illegally market your products
you know it's it's super cool man it's
it's great to see being licensed
facilities and also talking with
unlicensed people know what they think
and what they're doing with their lives
you know they're saying it's it's a sick
movement in the country right now I
think it's like I said it's one of those
last things that we have in humanity
everything's getting kind of like super
technology the super down pat you know
even to where there's cameras everywhere
yeah and there's a lot of dominance over
how people move and perceive their days
I think canvas also is one of those last
things for people who don't have money
to kind of become entrepreneurs easily
and be involved in a society that's that
they can form on their own
you know damn yeah cannabis being one of
those last sort of how these put these
sort of like plants these things from
the past that are finally being
integrated into our future society yeah
emphasis is kind of one of one of that
yeah I see that and drugs in general
being yet decriminalized in research and
developed now I just quick on hemp con
this is interesting because as you get
into cannabis business you get to do
cool things like go and showcase hemp
con so teach us about that yeah those
are the things that like I said I enjoy
you know the CEO standpoint school you
do all all the corporate stuff but this
really brings out the brand the team
people's ideas this is a community the
society as a whole will be there I'll be
there with a bunch of guys and workers
and will be there man so if anybody's
free and when watching it even yourself
come stop by come smoke I'm hanging out
you know and see what the industry is
about yeah mmhmm yeah that's a cow
palace March 8th through 10th 2019 for
those that are just listening with no
video in Daly City in California I had
pecan check out highways there and also
you know highways Co Young's links in
the bio check it out ok questions on the
way out that we like to ask our guests
this is simulation so we must ask you
are we in a simulation yes no I mean
it's it's a simulation of ideas being
brought you know to this podcast where
you know she's simulating just these
thoughts and how the world goes so it's
you know in a sense it's a simulation
you know they're saying our lives were
simulated going in going out David day
so that's saying yes to be intricate
yeah and then let's ask you about
and I ask you this one what is you you
know you want to full circle this back
because you you actually scald it you
know the seed right the seed of these
children being born into our world my
question then is what do you think are
some of these best guiding principles as
family having a family presence you know
the biggest thing for a seed is having
that older figure to water you you know
and feed you and show you a way people
some people grow better without having
away you know what I'm saying but I
think a lot of people need to be to be
led by somebody else and guided in the
right way or at least be in the right
environment society and I think that you
know there's a lot of ways this could go
about and I think also that you know the
Big C really is the government so the
government are are those of our father
figures you know saying that represent
the country as a whole that we need to
be more integrated from from the lowest
guys to the upper guys come up with fair
rules and regulations for people for
everything advancing in the future
cannabis technology you know saying
overpopulation there's a lot of things
that are gonna happen you know maybe in
our lives
you know I'm young I might see it at 80
but there's a lot of things that is up
to a father figure to determine you know
and I think that's also a big phrase and
choosing you know for instance whether
you want your kids to do this way or
that way whether you beat your kid
whether your kid doesn't have a father
and looks to somebody else as a father
and I think really rich people and poor
people that's a big disadvantage because
people can't relate as well and then
between different cultures because I've
see I've noticed that too you know
different cultures can't relate it's
also kind of like this seedling thing
we're from different fields so we grow
different ways and then you try to merge
them it's it's hard to merge you know
and you still even when you do that you
need that father figure to bring two
cultures together you know it's it's
really like that and I think there is no
father figure to bring rich and poor
together I think that it is dividing I
think that the poor people have some
points you know what I'm saying I grew
up around a lot of poor people a lot of
my friends are poor family members you
know I've seen that I went to a really
good school I seen a lot of rich people
and I see
how people think about other their other
race this other seed you know what I'm
saying amongst amongst it and that's
what I bring out an hour in highways you
know we're a family of all sorts we like
to talk and converse with everybody and
we like to bring that a family being
back to you know to our area to our
society and I think you know that we can
do some productivity and I can't but
cannabis men should be educating the
youth you know in a different light my
gosh I love the analogy of the seed and
the way that it's watered as this
environment and have family being a
major pillar guidance and leaders them
you know the child of the child of a
human is basically can't do [ __ ] went
because some children of other other of
other animals are born and they can
already move and feed themselves and
things like yeah we're being worth being
Noble as though we need the ownership
and yeah it's also raising people people
are babied also at young ages you know
saying I know some older people that
were able to process thing work at nine
years old you know and just hearing
that's like wow man you know we have
this cognitive thought at a young age
yes we're just baby - yeah you know -
saying and then you know you know we
can't coddle too much of course a whole
table too much we need to let the bird
fly out of the nest
um okay last question what's the most
beautiful thing in the world
wow man the most beautiful thing in the
world uh probably the most beautiful
thing in the world is probably a really
nice a nice scenic sight you know
whether it be looking up at some solar
eclipse you know or whether it's being
in Rome and seeing like like the
Colosseum or the Vatican you know we
love it we're doing it exactly you know
I think those are those are those are
some of the most beautiful things and I
think the other most beautiful thing is
having family and friends and a group
that all care for each other I think
it's a beautiful thing those are the two
most beautiful things you know and the
ugliest thing in this world is money
damn okay so seeing this beautiful
scenery also be like beautiful history
and then like this family this beautiful
family code cohesive community that kind
of stuff and then on the on the flip
side money is the ugliest yeah damn
there's a hell of truth to that hella
true to what you just said there and
it's I'm very excited I don't think many
people envision a post money world but
it's it's quite exciting to to really
paint your imagination vividly about how
civilizations could still flourish at
even greater extents I mean in a post
money world cuz it's extremely possible
it's just that where our imaginations
are restricted in terms of this like
this monetary exchange of time and of
goods absolutely this yeah yeah yeah I
think we have human race as a as a whole
we have a lot of really intelligent
things in our brain that that could get
out there you know I think that thinking
about those other things should be where
we should be instead of arguing between
each other you know I'm you know it's
hard for everybody to communicate
between other people other groups or
their races and the biggest thing is
that it still trickles up to the highest
form of a father or you know any type of
society you notice like not just a
democratic society you know and that's
the biggest things for everyone to come
together back alright where are we at
you know yes what do we want into with
everybody and everything you know who
knows you know there's so many different
planets out there and it's so big we're
just such a tiny particle in this world
yes you know and there's so much
speculation that I think is cool to
bring upon not just speculating on the
dollar and just focusing on the dollar
instead of the other side you know from
the seed of cannabis to the seed of
children being born into the world this
has been super fun super wide-ranging my
man absolutely it's been a huge pleasure
pleasure thank you so much for coming
here on tea nice thank you yeah glad I'm
glad that you came on we had this you
know in-depth discussion this was super
fun local you know local community fifth
floor first first floor and the same
building so great to see highways
prospering and you guys growing and
teaching us about all of the intricacies
about what's actually going on as the
business of cannabis yep thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
does highways do any codes on there
check out do you guys do codes oh we're
coming up with it right now ok so you
should have some fur hem contour right
after hem con ok cool maybe we do a
simulation code once that's built in yep
maybe we do simulation code so so do
check out the link in the bio for that
as well check out the info in the bio
highways code give them a look check out
their Instagram as well get talking more
cannabis as a business conversations
around around our communities let's get
going on that everyone and give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you keep building out the
community and the conversation shout out
to Round of August for producing and
directing we love you very much and go
and build the future everyone keep
supporting artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in support them you can
support us if you believe in us below as
well
much love build the future take care
we'll see you soon peace
[Applause]
that's good that was an epic bro you got
oh
[Music]
you